[MUSIC PLAYIN]
MATTHEW O'CONNOR: Defending
the world's largest network
against constantly-evolving
cyber threats
has driven us to develop
advanced tools to help keep us
and our customers ahead.
I'm going to go into detail on
four ways we can help defend
your business critical data
and applications from some
of today's biggest
security threats.
Let's start with ransomware.
Recent Google research
shows cyber thieves
have made at least $25 million
from ransomware in the last two
years.
And this is expected to grow.
To protect ourselves
and our customers
from this and other
types of malware,
we've built multiple layers
of protection, most of which
are automated and available
to our customers by default.
First, our global visibility in
the malicious sites and content
makes detection
highly effective.
If you're a Gmail
user, we prevent
thousands of
malicious attachments
from ever reaching inboxes.
If something does
reach your inbox,
Google Safe Browsing
in our Chrome browser
protects users by identifying
dangerous links in email
and showing warnings
if users click on them.
This stops access
to any websites
which are known to
distribute malware.
If you've ever been blocked
from a site like this,
you've experienced
Safe Browsing at work.
Every minute of the day, we find
and label another malware site
and warn users of suspected
malware hundreds of times.
In Google Drive,
all files undergo
a malware scan prior to
any download or sharing.
Drive also stores files in
non-executable formats, which
prevent ransomware
from propagating.
Our Chrome operating
system continually
updates automatically,
ensuring it's highly resistant
to malware compromise.
Applications are
sandboxed to prevent harm
to the host machine.
Often, these features
remove any need
for anti-malware or
anti-virus software.
And at the mobile device
level, every single day,
we check the health of over
400 million Android devices
and scan over 6 billion
mobile applications downloaded
to Android phones to make
sure they're not infected.
Safe Browsing protects over
2 billion mobile phones,
laptops, tablets, and
other devices which
use Google software.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now let's look at denial
of service attacks.
A Distributed Denial of
Service attack, or DDoS attack,
is an attempt to make
an online service
unavailable by overwhelming
it with traffic
from multiple sources.
It can have a huge impact if
businesses aren't adequately
prepared.
As a Google Cloud customer,
you are protected by default
to this type of attack, as the
scale of our infrastructure
enables us to simply
absorb many of them.
For context, a huge
attack last year
had a strength of around
1 terabit per second.
The whole internet has
a bisection bandwidth
of 200 terabits per second.
Now, when you compare this
to a single Google Data
Center, which has a
bisection bandwidth of $1,300
terabits per second,
you can see we
have built-in level of internal
capacity multiple times
that of any traffic
load we anticipate.
When there is an
attack, we have time
to isolate it and address it.
But we don't stop there.
In Google Cloud
Platform, customers
benefit directly from our
central DDoS mitigation
service that provides additional
multi-tier, multi-layer
protections and further
reduces the risk
to services running behind
our Google front ends.
When the system detects
an attack is taking place,
it can configure load balancers
to drop or throttle traffic
associated with the attack.
So what do we do to
prevent data breaches?
It's critical to know
where sensitive data is.
But that can be difficult
in complex systems.
At Google, we encrypt
our customers' data
in different ways, depending
upon what the data is doing.
And all of this
happens by default
with no user action required.
Data is potentially vulnerable
to unauthorized access
as it travels across the
internet or within networks.
Because it's linked to
most ISPs in the world,
Google's private
global network helps
to improve the security
of data in transit
by limiting the hops
across the public internet.
Any data traveling from
a customer's device
to Google's Cloud is
protected using HTTPS or TLS,
limiting opportunities for
traffic to be intercepted.
In fact, Google was the
first major cloud provider
to enable this by default.
And Google, we encrypt
our customers' data
in different ways, depending
upon what the data is doing.
Whether it is stored in
a database or in transit
to and from Google, it
all happens by default
with no user action required.
Data is encrypted at
the hardware layer
inside of our data center.
That way, it can
only be decrypted
in our cloud on another
verified Google machine.
When it's stored,
data is broken up
into numerous different shards
and sent to different servers.
This guards against
hackers and is
good for disaster recovery and
business continuity, insuring
against natural disasters,
unplanned down times
or equipment failures.
When you call up a document
in Google Drive, for example,
the document is recalled from
all of its storage points,
decrypted, and reassembled
in the blink of an eye.
Additionally, as customers,
you have the option
of managing encryption keys
with our Cloud Key Management
Service, or even supplying
your own encryption keys
if you're looking for additional
granular levels of control.
Data loss prevention is
an effective technology
to ensure that sensitive data
doesn't leave the organization
or get accessed by people
that it's not intended for.
In Google Cloud
Platform and G Suite,
users can find and
secure sensitive content,
minimize what data they collect,
and implement data governance
policies.
Our DLP API helps you to
manage and run analytics
on your Cloud data without
introducing additional risk
to your organization.
It provides fast,
scalable classification
and optional redaction for
over 40 sensitive data types,
like credit card numbers, names,
passport numbers, and more.
As you can see here, it can be
used to automatically classify
or redact sensitive data from a
text stream before you write it
to disk, generate logs,
or perform analysis on it.
Finally, let's look at an attack
that many organizations are
concerned about--
phishing.
According to the 2017 Verizon
Data Breach Investigations
Report, 90% of all
incidents and breaches
that involve social
actions by external actors
include phishing.
Everyone is
overwhelmed with email.
And it just takes one
person to hurriedly
click on a rogue message to
have a phishing incident.
If you've ever seen an
email that looks like this,
you'll know what
I'm talking about.
Our first defense is to
prevent phishing emails
from ever reaching people.
Gmail filtering blocks the
majority of malicious email.
And our global
visibility across users
makes this visibility
highly effective.
Gmail also restricts
the use of file types
that carry a high potential
for security risks.
Even inside a compressed
file, if a malicious link
gets through, the next
layer of protection
is Safe Browsing in Chrome,
which prevents users
from visiting known
phishing websites where
their credentials can be
stolen or malware installed
on their device.
Then, even if an attacker
manages to gain the credentials
they were looking for, such
as a username and password,
we provide two-factor
verification and security
keys, which make the use
of compromised credentials
extremely difficult.
Instead of entering
a unique code
as the second factor at
sign-in, Security Key
sends us cryptographic
proof that user's
on a legitimate Google site and
that they have their security
keys with them.
A physical action is required.
And since most
hijackers are remote,
their efforts can be thwarted,
because they cannot get
possession of the security key.
To increase control
further, businesses
can take advantage of Security
Key Enforcement, which
allows Google Cloud
administrators to enable
two-step verification that
forces users to use security
keys as the second factor.
Security keys work with
Google accounts at no charge.
But you'll need to buy a
compatible USB device directly
from a U2F-participating vendor.
Finally, if a Chromebook
somehow gets compromised
as a result of a
phishing attack,
it can quickly and easily be
restored to a known good state.
As you can see, we're constantly
innovating for our customers
to help prevent compromises
all across the stack.
Compared to legacy security
approaches, using Google Cloud
means that typical deployment
is faster and scale
much more easily.
Automation is easier.
Functionality evolves and
improves more quickly.
And often, the cost of
acquisition is lower.
[MUSIC PLAYING]